uh you know it's not easy to start from
square zero especially for some of these
streams who are so good at what they do
um so it's really uh hats off and and i
greatly greatly admire uh both of these
competitors and everybody in the
tournament so
it seems that the game is officially
underway here we go buckle up
the seat belts xpc quickly uh did a
hairstyle before
jeff you guys watched that hair flip but
that was interesting
good luck charm right there and we see
e4
and xqc taking his time on move one 30
seconds spent and finally going e5
all right i like this we're going to
see some solid opening play um
with 96 bishop c4 all right this is
actually what i have showed hafu
so i do like this opening i do like it a
lot um
i i showed her both bishop d5 and bishop
c4 bishop's the first italian
um followed we might say c3 d3 hafu is a
very principal player so we might see
some opening theory coming from her
actually
she wants to learn the main lines i'm
curious if xbc is already a little bit
lost enough
we can listen in because he's drawing
some uh
suspicious arrows is opening thoughtful
let's
see what's going on a fan of this
thing i think he's uh
scared of the fried liver thing
you're taking his time here
though try liver or not this is the real
question jack
what do you guys think i lost a lot of
time here this is really bad
i didn't get back though okay at least
he's aware of
this
it's okay i think the quick moves here
that are pretty good
or i can set up a foundation for the
future setting up the foundation for the
future could be pretty good too
spending a lot of time early to have a
good game plan and then later on
executing it by gaining time and having
in the run of thinking like two rounds
of thinking
yeah they're both oh she does it
i like that will impressive
know about d5 he was looking at it
that's nearly checkmate is it not
that would be pretty much checkmates
it's pretty much the only move here
that's the issue
yeah unfortunately the fried liver is
one of those openings
he's queen
[Music]
where's the bank knight f7 is the boom
yeah yeah
that's pretty good yes thank god he
found it oh my god
but knight 65 there's a very famous trap
where white takes on f7
will happen yeah the move here is
actually
not 965 right from black it's actually
knight a5
of course very difficult move to find
once again
oh and he plays knight takes about okay
yeah nine eight five he's gonna have
anything
like there is this there's nothing
natural right
i got a baby
and now
but knight takes f7 is very dangerous
night sacrifice
i'm in a good spot yeah
you don't know it's very hard to see i'm
not sure if hafu has actually
closely checked the fry lever because
she i feel like what she did for this
game
against xqc was a little bit more on the
side of playing for a trick out of the
opening
um because i do know that she plays you
know the italian and all that stuff so
um i i'm actually with also the time
she's spending i'm not too certain that
she knows the knight takes f7 move of
course that's not to say she won't be
able to find it over the board it's just
not the simplest of moves to make other
good moves to play d3 here
keeping that knight on g5
very solid solid move yeah
d3 is is is good because you know
for for beginner of course oh queen of
three is really interesting
yeah hitting that eval bar took a big
yes because of queen takes
g5 which you know queen f3 does
unfortunately
leave the knight hanging on g5 but the
knight on d5 is also hanging so it's not
the end
of the world white will be threatening
check
definitely playing cc is familiar with
that particular threat though
he knows it he knows it very very well
[Music]
well this is you know if they get into
this position
um hafu still has very very good chances
but you know that's not to say black's
position
is it's not like you know completely
fine now
um just because of that hanging knight
on g5
so what do you think sorry go ahead no
no i was just
bishop e6 or queen takes g5
both natural looking moves xqc does look
for
captures and checks though so i do think
queen takes g5 is very very possible
from xqc
andrea what's your prediction i honestly
have no idea because i was getting
distracted by his camera because he's
like
yelling and hitting himself and like all
these reactions i have no idea what to
expect of xqc's move here
the wooden shield has been set up so he
doesn't take the freedom oh he's being
honest he's playing it safe
um i think this works out okay
yeah it's a wooden shield just defending
the pawn defending the knight
it's it's a very solid move i think
avoiding complications for him was smart
especially because he's lower on time
yeah the thing about hafu is also that
she actually does
spend quite a lot of time she's from
from my experience with coaching her she
does get into time trouble
fair bit so like xqc said that when we
did our listening
he is um you know setting this up for
the future so
all right bishop takes the five not not
a great move because now
that bishop on c4 was a really good one
an xqc can recapture with his bishop
attacking the queen
who should have taken the bishop ruining
black spawn structure instead now xuc
definitely with the advantage
if he plays right and i think oh
yeah do we want to do another listening
yeah
absolutely this is a big moment
okay that's gotta be
that's the question mark question mark
can you realize that white took a knife
though he
yeah that takes time he didn't take that
blocker what are you gonna do
this no he can't do that no you're not
gonna do that okay the problem with
queen takes g5 is that there's bishop
takes
um
[Music]
oh no right
he
do we want to do a quick listening um
[Music]
but now i don't think she's gonna give
him another chance
problem is you take the bishop white
takes and wins the rook for the fork
i don't think that xqc realized that
there was bishop 66 after 85.
um yeah this is this is gonna be a
little bit
scary now for black he had he had that
one chance to play
yeah i think what happened in this
thought process is eden c
uh knight g5 thinking the first time it
was realized that like one move later
and not so distracted
yeah yep and it's yeah andre you talked
about this earlier that's just something
that happened sometimes yeah and had he
taken on d5 now of course the game would
have continued but
a very big initiative there for he's
definitely going to analyze this
detects his mistakes and come back
better next time but
what a fascinating opening for sure
it's one of those things where it's like
you're not really certain
um right she's not very certain about
this opening history and spirit
she thought it was like a trick that she
planned and she got caught a little bit
unaware um when black
made some good news it's pretty funny
how fool has not said
a single word this entire game is that
focus
that's what i've not seen
she's just nodding she's very very calm
and collected i think
even when she knows she's winning she
still stays
very serious threats to checkmates
yeah for sure
oh okay yeah he should be seven
from xqc he doesn't have time
consumption telling all the story
i think he's realizing now he did not
find the winning move
yeah but you know it it's it's good
he he he realized that if he takes c6 he
would have lost a whole an entire rook
right so this is
this is putting um you know a bandage on
the room
yes although the bleeding does continue
after queen takes f7 check
up a piece with interest for white some
chances remaining for black pixels he's
got to make his king safe here
tapu is kind of on a castle very good
technique
oh she's staying defensive
i guess she keeps the pawns forked but
she will still win i know i could keep
attacking here
or here but oh
she
yeah that's not bad at all i like your
safe play like she's already
very in a winning position so might as
well be safe not allow anything
indeed definitely um
i mean most of the moves here are you
know
better for white just because she does
have an extra extra piece sorry
and d4 another excellent move exposing
look at that developing the bishop
attacking the queen
you'll definitely see this queen attack
he pointed out earlier in his thoughts
um and you know black's king being the
center of the board is very
uncomfortable very very uncomfortable
for black you know this whole opening
was just quite unfortunate because it's
like like we said before right like
you know coming out the opening for
beginners is really important because
you can be either winning
or losing yeah exactly what happened
and xqc just did not win the coin toss
for this one he found
d5 on demand very impressive but just
didn't quite manage the task after that
definitely and uh you know hoffa didn't
make the best choices
exactly either but it was just you know
who makes that
you know last blunder or makes that last
great move right that that's what
dictates the coming out of the opening
as the chess expression goes the one who
makes the second to last mistake wins
is one trespasser that's a perfect
description
for this game yeah well
his queen's under attack running low on
time too they've only played 11 moves
but both players have spent a lot of
time we just get to show you know
or you know maybe maybe maybe they have
prepared it but but i'm just
implying from the time you said here
neither player prepared this opening
completely unexpected and it just was
did not go in excuse his favorite but he
played some really
impressive moves you want to go back to
xqc side
yeah let's do it let's see what he's
struggling with here
i can't i'm done uh take take i'm
playing so bad right now
these moves are so these these moves are
so hard
to justify he can't even blame himself
it was like
opening theory he really shouldn't be
blaming himself not like developing it
um
i feel like a lot of people she's castle
and developing the house honestly
it's okay i like playing as black i'll
just wait next night
[Music]
is a very difficult team to play and
then so
just being in the beginning of the game
it's not simple it's not over yet
put some music on
okay that's good that's a good mentality
it's definitely never time to design
[Music]
okay i i i'm
take take take take take take and i'm
then i'm behind
um what else i can do bing bang he moves
thing
bang
i'm missing something here i'm still
minus three and i'm so developed
good observation
[Music]
dude about to get finessed
something's about to happen i'm telling
you dude dude she's brewing something up
[Laughter]
she's brewing some sort of potion
i'm not seeing it
said i don't like this position believe
it or not yeah i'm really curious
that's the story of chess both players
think the other is about to deliver
checkmate
exactly on it goes yeah
let's do a quick listen in on hoffy's
side he's one minute
what is he brewing
[Music]
yeah definitely not what he was
expecting
i mean if he takes us it's a queen trade
that xqc was seemingly very defeated and
she does not
she's definitely not letting that
confidence get to her
definitely not yeah she doesn't even
look that happy about
her position i'm not gonna lie i feel
like she's down a piece like i said
about half thor
the opposite is true
[Music]
wow the clocks are really ticking down
for xqc2
at 50 seconds already
very good move keeping that extra pawn
i do have to say hoffman's um blanket
looks really comfortable
yeah i'm actually thinking the same
thing
got the atmosphere set up
for full focus yeah you want to be
comfortable
that reminds me
that is not oh oh she had bishop f4
she gonna find it oh no rookie one is
also good by the way
that's a really cool move the bishop
before when's the queen
oh we should search i think
realizes it and that is going to do it
[Music]
okay we'll get our next game
not the white pieces bishop d6 is the
best you can do
but you can i can
move the queens yeah yeah sorry i'm
gonna make it
also move the queen yeah i would have
moved the queen yes
[Music]
okay you buttered it
okay i like that i like that yellow
oh
he wins a full well actually he wins in
exchange if you
move the night out
definitely game is not over excuse me
some
good tactics
he's making good quick moves i'm
spending checkmate
i'm threatening checkmate
[Music]
what
exactly yeah he saw it
that reaction though
[Music]
that was close it's a close it was a
good thing
[Music]
but she's got to make a back ring
not to keep her back crank weak that's
important
maybe h3 and look at that yep no
ice skater yep today no tricks
zero that's exactly what i expected
doubling the rooks he's trying his best
but it's just too much material here
yeah he missed something
[Music]
it's just one of those positions he
definitely gave him his best
effort there but hafu is not the type of
player that will
throw a winning game i mean she did do
that in her first round but now she's
been taking it very seriously like
every threat
definitely um this is just one of those
times when it's like
well xqc is going to be most likely
losing this game but he has very good
chances
in the next game to come back you know
he's seeing tactics
uh hafu has not been playing you know
perfect chess for anything
so we might also see hoff will be a
little bit more cautious with her
opening choice in the next game just
because this one
there were some good chances for ecstasy
yeah
i agree completely i mean she wants to
get out of the opening
in an equal position her middle games
her fundamentals are definitely better
but she knows that xcc can be dangerous
and tactic so i agree
she's going to put the emphasis on solid
opening
get into a playable middle game and
sort of try to prove her superiority
there sure
and just with the fact that this game is
you know basically taking
the full time um 16 seconds to two
minutes they're both players are playing
very seriously
and it's it's really really encouraging
to see also xqc play this game out
all the way to the end right very very
you know principled he's
great he's doing great he's really doing
great
i was happy as the first time i saw a
smile on hathu's face
she looked so worried during the whole
game yeah what's your thinking face but
she did just
have a little smile so allowing aligning
herself
wow a little bit of that's a glimpse man
it's disrespectful
yeah exactly yeah
imagine smiling during your game huh
what's that
ridiculous okay trading she knows
she knows her principles very well now
you can vacuum up the pawns one after
the other all with check
yeah i mean what we saw from this game
both players are very strong but both
can miss like
the most obvious well not too obvious
moves but
they made the same type of blunder in
the beginning
yeah um i mean you know beginners will
always
misplay certain moves and it's just like
even if you don't know that opening even
for a stronger player
like if you just don't know about the
fried liver what are the chances you
you know you find a 985
all the way all the way back right um
there is just
really no spotting 95 this is the
correct yeah in this position
and then theory goes bishop b5 c6 and
you take and this is just a position
where white is up upon and black has
compensation but
once again not something that is very
likely to be known
um yeah and it happens even at the grand
master level i can confirm that
sometimes you get into an unfamiliar
position and um
if you don't know it it can be hard to
find a move on demand
um no matter how experienced you are
yeah now one last prayer stay all mate
but
even that is far-fetched of course yeah
do you guys want to have vegan tofu
let's do that
oh we missed it that's why i do a bullet
just kick it all take my night go ahead
no way she makes free food for it okay
she's gonna do it louder oh my god don't
steal me
please don't steal me hosuh
it needs more confidence yeah i think
come on
[Music]
what is wrong with me oh my god okay
it's fine
that's a good move actually
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no and then and then the [ __ ]
dream
for the second year
okay i don't think can i have time to
just find that
i don't think half of being so
nervous is is quite something yeah i
mean
that's i i've talked about that with her
so many times like in our last coaching
session i said
it's gonna have a little bit more
confidence like don't be scared of ghost
threats like give yourself a little bit
more credit
but she's a very humble player
definitely
that's a great quality but you know i
mentioned this before
these streamers they're all used to
streaming before a huge audience but
chess
is a different kettle of fish you know
it can still cause those butterflies in
the shaking hands
oh excuse me is analyzing his game oh
he's
go go to stream real quick yep
look at that face of disbelief
now it would not have been over but it
would have been a very very strong
attack
he's realizing he could have had a win
almost but
i should have won
the computer here the face tells all
he's actually a brilliant analyst here
i think i understand it a little bit
deep but you know yeah
why is
yeah what's funny though also shows like
both hafu also as soon as their
game manages like oh do i have time to
analyze like right away as soon as the
game
ends no matter the result they want to
analyze their game i love that
very good qualities here indeed
but they gotta get ready for the next
game because it is starting any second
now
with xqc being what are we going to see
in the opening and we see the french
from hafu yeah she does love the french
i remember yeah she learned this opening
she she's learned a lot of different
openings and she has like quite
honestly quite the arsenal of opening
prep now so
this will be interesting to see what she
does as she usually plays yep
e65 going for the french i think we
should uplift the board
all right let's do that i'm not probably
as familiar
for xbc bishop d3 i've seen him do this
before
what's funny is i was watching his game
with tafu i think it was against
uh finton he did this similar thing and
i told her it's not a good strategy
the issue with this move is that it
blocks the c1 bishop uh from developing
so it's
it's far from a disaster but it is you
know a little bit subpar
so we'll see if xcc can maybe fianchetto
you put that bishop on b2
something like that but a solid choice
indeed from hafu
yeah for sure um there is very little
that could go wrong this opening for
black
we might see e5 from xqc we're just
pushing the knight back
might be a good idea but not not quite
certain
if um xqc has played this kind of
opening before
probably more used to seeing e4e5 lines
so this will be really interesting too
and it's a very interesting strategy
for a relative beginner to play one of
these less common openings and catch
their opponent off guard
it also exposes you to more to different
types of structures
than just always playing e45 okay so
this bishop but this bishop d3 is not a
real opening though
it's well bishop d3 is a move if you
play
yeah to d4 on move two and then then
bishop d3 is alive
yeah yeah that is great he just missed
that one move
okay you made it seem like it was a
lion's house
as you speak i am looking this i am
actually going to check if this has ever
happened in the tournament game before
[Applause]
no let's see is bishop d3 novelty
it let's see it has been played
you will fall off your chairs over a
hundred times
oh why i'm actually not various types of
players
i'm not that surprised it's not that
honestly it doesn't look like basically
203 times it was first played in the
year 1895
by actually a very strong player he's
bringing out an ancient gem
he studied that game from 1895. he did
henry
uh edward one of the strongest players
of the 19th century after human opening
his name played this move so
definitely you know brunes was a
tactical player as far as i can remember
and xqc you know is just
imitating burn um
reincarnation
otherwise it works the other way yeah
yeah
um yeah this is this is this is a
pretty decent position for why i'm not
going to lie the queen is going to be
chilling on e4 there's no knight that
can kick it out
of course he did give up one of the
bishops so hafu does
have the pure bishops but not a
significant
advantage for either side ebola does say
it's very evil
believe it or not even this position has
occurred in tournament practice four
times
so we're following the famous game
machado against fernandez 1984.
which of course they have both any
brazilian championship
in 1984 they have both studied this game
extensively i wouldn't pass
i would have put it past halfway to the
jefferson like honestly she might have
all you know with all the preparation
all the grind she's done she might yeah
i went exactly and b4 is a
novelty i think novelty yeah well bishop
c5 is a novelty
okay bishop c5 novelty from hoffa where
are
we
yeah one thing about playing against xqc
is always going to take you out of the
book so no matter
how much opening preparation you do it
can't help you too much
you know that's actually something i've
discovered if you if you
are not certain about what you're doing
your opponent won't know either and
that's a winning strategy for me
honestly poker tournaments
actually b4 is a great move if he can
understand that he needs to put that
bishop on b2
along diagonal um who is it that likes
uh to put the bishop there was it um
yeah style um put that bishop in the
long diagonal threatened upon will he
see this move is the question
uh you're not don't sound too gone with
it
yeah you guys yeah let's listen
to let's listen let's see it mm-hmm
[Music]
oh he did it
wow
[Music]
incredible
to assume anyone in this chat could do
bishop a nightmare that
says there's some person noah
the grand lord
one thousand that's that's life i think
that's
the last games vlogs
[Music]
can she do that
[Music]
yeah so he he anticipated that she could
castle in that position but
especially with the queen out it's i
think it is safer to go with f6
and avoid any attack on g7
yeah this is like a very good way to
stop against any
future attack like andrea said so
you know hafu is is very very focused
she's looking at the board i've never
seen her focus before
i she usually is very unfocused yeah
definitely
i'm glad the first time she's turned her
phone off and man the music and the
party in the
room i know she's too
it's just so interesting you know let's
do a quick listening for hafu as well i
mean she
she's quite quiet but yeah you know it's
just like
there's so much to do oh man
you can't do this and attack this pawn
so i can't get my pieces out right now
i actually have so much pressure on me
crazy
what the hell is this move it's so good
that's really good because i let him get
in keto and with the tempo
that's
honestly has started this game out
really really well
yeah i mean you wouldn't expect it with
bishop d3 but it did turn out good
following the footsteps of harry edwin
and uh
if i do cake so i have to do about this
first but then he's gonna go
there but it's interesting and then
in this position i think she could
castle
she should she's starting to block yeah
otherwise she's just so stressed
oh my god it's so slow but it stops as
night jumps
and that allows me to develop
oh i do not feel good
what is he threatening yeah this move
doesn't actually accomplish that much of
castles exactly
but i i think the castle
yes admirable that he sees this stuff oh
my gosh
yeah he has a good eye mercy xqp
i really like the amount of credit she's
giving her upon like no matter the
rating difference
i think it's also very well deserved
this game because actually
he's playing good chess yes
like just just extremely like aggressive
i think
he's doing what he needs to do what are
his threats that's everything
he's threatening this he's threatening
this
i told her ghost threats i said don't do
this
there's not any real threats what does
he do
and xqc is actually up on time now
he's overthinking it sometimes just
going with your instinct is the best
thing you can do
what if i do this oh my god
not that c6 is bad but but her
hesitation might cost her i mean if she
makes too many weaknesses
it could get you know dicey yeah the
time is definitely an issue here
i can't think of it this time it's very
close i
i couldn't think of a good play for him
his mic can't go anywhere
he can't really take on this
it's a very uncomfortable position but
um i don't see a
threat let's see what he's thinking yeah
i'm a little bit worried that he's
taking this long
maybe he's deciding where to put the
knife
dude what am i doing i need to play safe
i need stuff thinking about this fancy
strats i i it's not gonna work
his observations are so cool over here
everything he does wrong
um
there's not many places to move here
bang
[Music]
i don't even know just get him out of
there dude
okay let's say i move this over here she
moves that over here
good calculation but is that what she
takes
terrible it's it's just terrible wait no
interesting ideas they're both not happy
with their position and both of their
positions are fine
i know exactly they're both good
they're overthinking just a little bit i
mean
they're very similar in these ways they
all feel very different
i don't even know anymore but like their
main weakness like over stretching
themselves out
i'm so slow like i did that three
minutes left i'm ivory through the game
hurts
when he was just up on time yeah no i
didn't i got this
swinging back i'm developed decently
well i think i don't know
there's the important words of
encouragement you got to bring your
there's something i'm not thinking about
too
oh man this is what we like to make sure
this is still working i can just back it
up once and then i can move my queen
whatever i want
backing the pawn on b4
um this is mesmerizing like i can just
watch them think i
[Music]
he really likes that e5 square that's
what i'm going to say
this yep there we go that
this that is not worth sacrificing for
no this is not going to give me anywhere
i'm not sure
why he likes the e5 square so much
they both they're soft bronzers like
they're so abstract
and these ideas but here you should make
a move like slightly in like seconds
looks so scared i don't know if this is
good to do
inside castle yeah
actually just to capture her facial
expression
wow where did they want to go
she has a free pawn man she's letting it
get here
i take he comes out
go here i can also do this
stops this but then his rook comes here
it's gonna be a time scramble folks yeah
buckle up
i'm in my seat i'm on the edge of my
seat already
three minutes okay
there's a lot of my bishops ideas that
you know
i'm not quite sure where they're coming
from well
it's like two boxers and they're afraid
to throw the first punch there literally
walking around the ring and there we go
all right we have the first punch
we do
the first move yeah sorry go ahead he
must complete his development i was just
to say
try to get that attack going on
center all right c3
is going to be a very good
let's bring it back
all right these bishop trades are
probably going to work out
um actually in xqc's favorite just
because
you know simplified position you won't
have
a lot of material to lose everything's
so solid for him yeah
he's way developed he's developed way
more than halfway has
his pawn structure healthy
so he's definitely got compensation for
the pun but castle quickly this andrea
you pointed this out this is where he
needs to save time
yep 94 very aggressive he's he keeps
going for it i like the style of play
centralizing the night attacking you
safe top he's gonna defend that energy
will
push that pawn out you can trade queens
yeah here you can really see the effects
of
uh one too many pond moves not the
sexiest trades but
development i just need to get this
thing out of here and if she would have
stayed
back i need to be confident that i can
win an end game
i don't think that we need five moves
because this creates the double pawns
you're going to be a tough end game i
mean
on the other hand she might be a little
bit more experienced than games she's
done some in-game training but
excuse me got to drop his mind back to
f3 which he does attacking e5
the xqc has a better position but i
think overall to
better end game players so what will
overweight so
this is true mark's advantage is not
fast but but it is quite significant
yeah yeah yeah will anybody castle in
this game though
do you want to play our best
put his knight on c4 instead he would
have had a fork on d6 with his knife
great well i do think that this e pawn
will be dropping
at some point regardless um just because
it's so difficult for her for
for um to defend it but you know knight
g5 might be interesting now
there is knight c5 um let's see where
xcc oh he does put his knight on g5
okay so he's attacking both this is a
good move
um hoff does have knight c5 which you
know defends both pawns but
still very very active position for um
xqc's tonight it's very
a very very quality game yeah absolutely
knight
go ahead oh other doesn't say our
devil's pawns are a huge weakness and
xtc has pretty easy play like
castle will put his rooks on the e file
the target is so obvious for where he
needs to attack
well we'll still need to see is anybody
going to castle here what are your
predictions guys
i think no no because uh half was going
to put her king on e7 to defend the e4
they have six pawn
exclusive might castle actually she just
solved her pawn structure
you missed the the obvious weakness here
but i find not a great move she's
creating more weaknesses on those dark
squares xqc will try to put either a
rook or a knight there
but one minute on the clock oh this is
going to get tense folks
this is going to be a time scramble
you see going after the bishop which is
i did it again
well he's got to activate his rooks d4
would be a good move
[Music]
there we go
he's got a rookie three wait what is he
doing played a brilliant move here
locking her pawn there now she can
easily double and he is staying on the
defensive side
yup it's not gonna be easy to break
through but with 55 seconds this will be
hard to defend for xbc
i can't just play not rookie wins the
pawn yep
he recognized it right away
[Music]
now black breaks through this gets very
very
now it was too difficult under the time
pressure
[Music]
oh no the background noise
i threw dude so well it's just like
experiencing games really there
now who's played so much
oh those double pawns i mean those uh
sorry pear pass balls would be dangerous
okay yeah
doing everything he can he's creating a
spot of his own he is not over yet
he's fighting
come on i can do this
how do i make this work away i really
like his thought process
he's staying positive
hey is just quietly pushing the pulse of
the board
oh rick b7 would have been his last
chance there maybe
at least twice but now yeah
[Music]
oh he sees it awesome
it's going to be close though c4 g5 this
is that we're going to be someone
stopping black's king
from coming to the e7 yeah and if you
rip the g3 chest to take that oh it's
not going anywhere
66 very good move forward white trucks
give it up
direct v8 has to play
[Music]
wait what happened
giving xcc a draw oh that was cute
because he offered to drop it it wasn't
running out of time
a little bit now that she can relax and
of course
already qualifying into the bracket so
yeah
that was definitely gracious you know
that was like one last hurrah
when he was like eff it he just stacks
his work tries to push
it was a good effort all right
um and we're going to have break and
i'll also take this time to say
uh goodbye to chat andrea and daniel
will be doing the interview with xqc and
hawfu they both played amazing chess
today so i hope all of chat
is giving them lots of energy and love
thank you nemo pleasure pleasure
commentating with you and uh all right
thank you for being a great
co-commentator see you later absolutely
see you guys welcome back
ladies and gentlemen to the pogchamps we
have just witnessed an incredible match
between
xqc and its hafu uh wichita
won um amazing games with tofu uh
just crushing it well congratulations to
you uh
facing the very very top resistance of
xtc
walk us through uh your thoughts on the
match
um give us the blow-by-blow of how you
felt
well the first game i started studying
the fried liver
but i didn't get too deep so i think i
blundered
but apparently he didn't take advantage
of it i was analyzing it as we started
the ice cream
yeah you guys were actually both doing
the same analysis
after and i'm assuming you saw the
moment where xbc had
uh almost winning oh i didn't get there
yet but i will look at it with you after
yeah we'll be doing some another
coaching session after but yeah
and that was theory that neither of you
guys are familiar with and
had winning chances what opening
i'll show you i'll show you my dad um
yeah that was kind of loose on my end
and then um
the second game he actually put me in so
much pressure
yeah i was in a really bad position it
felt
i i'm looking at the analysis and it
said that i was fine but it didn't feel
that way
because i couldn't move my queen size
queen side pieces
and it's suggesting i castle but i just
maybe
maybe in like a perfect play from that
point on after castling but it felt like
i couldn't move
i can't move the bishop because his
queen is hitting that pawn
and then i can't move the knight because
he can just push the pawn so then i
thought of you know prepping the knight
jump with
um what is it a6
yeah yeah a main thing for that
um for like what i told you before was
the ghost starts like like you said you
know
he was putting a lot of pressure on you
and constantly attacking but
computer says that he's not really much
better mostly just because his moves
were intimidating i'll show you
i'll show you when we're doing a
coaching session um later unfortunately
you can't access the board right now
but it was just the main thing about the
ghost rest that we
talked about earlier like you you
you seem so stressed out that game which
i mean his moves were intimidating but
all you gotta do is castle like a little
bit early on
and you'd be okay it felt like if i
castled though because it wanted me to
castle
king's side and it felt like i couldn't
move my queen side pieces whereas
it felt like he could reroute his pieces
much easier and quick
quicker but that's why i didn't like
castling there right
practically it was hard easier to play
uh to play white there
yeah yeah yeah was actually quite solid
i mean it was really interesting um
pretty pretty instructive stuff yeah we
never played something like that i was
really happy when he traded
his knight for my light squared bishop i
was like yes
it's dead thank goodness and xcc with a
very
finding very interesting idea of putting
that knight on d5 so
both of you really enterprising uh
original chess throughout the match
hoffa we all know and admire how hard
you have worked
uh throughout um but how do you sort of
avoid burnout
how do you manage the necessity to work
while at the same time
um you know keeping yourself refreshed
i mean i am the prize there's only a few
more days and
um i have really tough opponents ahead
hopefully plural
hopefully i can take that and i know
there's a lot of horse and fans
but um oh yeah the chat he'll cheer him
on when it's not even his day to play
but don't let that intimidate you
nah i mean i know forsen he's super nice
and it'll be a really fun match
um but yeah he's scary i'm scared of it
he's like
one of the people i was scared of coming
into the tournament
and uh yeah we'll see how we do
wait forsen was one of the players you
were scared
okay i wanted to ask you because um oh i
think
is it and i think we've been we've been
joined by xtc
welcome hello and what's up guys
well congratulations on a very well
played match uh xkc and thank you for
joining us
um well we know the match didn't go your
way but could you talk us through some
of your thoughts uh on these really
interesting games
sure man uh it feels really odd to be
congratulated when i lose
um while i was raised um you don't get a
participation award the other winner you
lose
so um it's a little bit odd but uh
uh i knew it was gonna be a tough match
yo and i didn't really prep for the
match up
and um i i had a couple blenders it
wasn't too bad it was pretty good
it was all right um also
also this is other words i live by if i
don't put in the effort i can't complain
about the results
and that's kind of the case here that's
a good attitude but i definitely think
you should give yourself more credit
like the second game i was even thinking
might go into armageddon because
the opening so you have a weird strength
you didn't prepare any opening and we
could see
but like just those attacking moves you
were doing hafu was really feeling the
pressure
it wasn't until like the end game where
the tables really turned because that's
where her experience shines through
because she's played
so so many games probably more than i've
played in the last month but
until like the last few moves and then
game was tied
very close position yeah you see i i'm
still exploring chess
right and um lately
i've been playing optional a couple
times you know i'm still like
discovering like very
rudimentary uh uh things that you guys
are probably already doing chances
because you're good you can see all
these things happening yeah one of the i
so i noticed it
is like sacrificing into a check
into getting something in so i i kept
putting my pieces up
to look for like a sneaker that you
wouldn't see like just throwing a piece
in there
sacrifice and getting another one and i
knew that if i did something she could
possibly miss it
and i kept trying to push that it's why
my pieces were always up and always
always like uh
going forward with them because that's
one of the concepts that i that i that i
saw or learned
so maybe there's other stuff that i
should uh yeah i would learn
that concept oh daniel you first no i
was just very quickly going to say that
xcc you're moved three in the french in
the second game that bishop move out
at first we thought it was it was
uncommon but we we noticed that it was
first played
over a hundred years ago by actually one
of the strongest 19th century players so
you followed in the footsteps and uh we
really appreciated the originality
um yeah andrea go ahead i was gonna say
we could definitely see those concepts
in play and they're paying off because
asu was spending so much time and even
though sometimes they were mostly ghost
threats it was definitely intimidating
play you just need to find to
balance it out with more defensive moves
that you can also play faster and save
your time on the clock
yeah i'm pretty bad late game two minute
game is so bad
like um i feel like late game is
something that you kind of just get a
grasp of like over time we're playing
like a lot of like hundreds of games
you know we have to think about it that
much you kind of just you're able to you
know like like do it just by seeing it
uh and my game is so bad like um
i'm just moving pieces and like yeah my
pawns have to go up yeah you're going up
this guy over there
they're going up you're going yeah i
mean there was a moment when both of you
were
you know thinking that the other had
this nefarious plan
up their sleeve but um yeah very very
interesting positions uh
indeed in both games there's so much
pressure in the second game
i i thought you were gonna take that one
yeah
um i thought i was getting somewhere
with that uh until i blundered the
the rook but even then i think i think
it was already over but uh
i thought i had it back it's okay though
yeah i didn't expect it to be so close i
mean
hafu i i notice you also don't really
underestimate any of your opponents but
there's obviously a huge rating gap
and the second game majority of the game
it was played equal on both sides
how did you feel about that food yeah i
mean he
just good moves and i actually thought
he was gonna take it because
i couldn't move my queen side like i
said and i thought
i just thought it was over because it
felt like he could move his pieces very
freely and it felt like i couldn't at
all
so i think if he found you know one or
two more threats
he could have gotten there because
everything was tied
well probably the biggest objective
chance was in that first game that
really interesting line
where xtc had you taken that night and
you know as he found out after the game
it was a very very strong attack
but you did find the move d5 which we
were very impressed by on demand
in an unfamiliar position so lots of
good moments for sure
hey man all right well i guess i'll
grind my way through the consolation
bracket or the losing bracket yeah
and uh hopefully see some other people
there yeah you guys both have
very top chances in both of your
brackets so
we're looking forward to it absolutely
well
congratulations hafu and very well
played executive yeah
honorable match of chess and also it was
hey
sorry for uh is sending you guys up last
night uh last
morning uh evening whatever time it was
you made up for it with good play
exactly
thanks for being hungry thank you guys
bye